so Matt meets this dude at the hotel bar
and he like just lives around the corner
so he's just like drinking there yeah
and it just so happens they're both from
Philly and they kind of buddy up because
they're from Philly whatever I didn't
know this I come downstairs and this
dude is just there and Matt's like oh
this is my homey and I forget the
Monica's name I just shake his hand he's
like what's the word man what's going on
what do you guys want to do man
y'all want coke weed I'm like what the
[ __ ] I'm like this is your friend man
weird opener yeah weird oh yeah yeah you
know maybe maybe hey where you from
what's good do you guys plans for
tonight I mean just jumped right into it
I mean obviously he's a drug dealer just
because of how he doesn't even [ __ ]
he skips the foreplay goes right to it
and he goes like he's he starts to like
give us you know he's he's trying to
play us as though he's our he's really
our friends because you know the Philly
thing mm-hmm
oh you guys are from Philly I got you
man whatever you want to do man cuz if
we want coke weed we'll go to strip club
you want [ __ ] why check out guys I
don't give a [ __ ] let me know we were
like actually actually yeah we heard
that's what we were thinking about is
horse we're discussing how bad we wanted
to yeah wouldn't need some [ __ ] yeah
tonight so if you could get us some
[ __ ] that'd be great that'd be awesome
dude and definitely couple guys we could
use a few more hot guys in this clip
refers to him as [ __ ] I don't know it
was yeah it was it was like so harsh
she gave us a couple [ __ ] and you guys
must be the [ __ ] Wow welcome to our
Best Western make yourself at home you
know yeah I'm going on the store grab a
couple horrors what you want anything
yeah
so whatever the dude dude you just arts
kind of going on a tangent and he a
roughly just just cuts through the
conversation just cuts himself off with
I got a DMT at the crib you guys want to
do some DMT
this shit's [ __ ] awesome did it last
night you know I don't really [ __ ] with
psychedelics anymore man but you know my
brother came over last night he had it
and I said [ __ ] it man let's do it
so smoke this [ __ ] honestly it only
lasted like three minutes but it felt
like [ __ ] forever dawg
I say okay he's like that sounds like
hell yeah yeah any good he goes on to
say yeah so you know it was cool man it
was happy it wasn't like acid or
mushrooms where it could be a bad trip
you can never have a bad trip on DMT bro
and I and I wanted to say haven't you
only done it once though I do if I'm
gonna trust the DMT opinion is gonna be
yours anyway then he says yeah I was out
of my body I was like surfing the sky
and [ __ ] and in whatever and it goes on
to describe his trip and I said cool
well the [ __ ] are you man this was just
in a span of like five minutes this is I
just wanted to cut him off I don't know
you what the what the [ __ ] was your name
again yeah dude I just I don't know you
enough to know this information bro yeah
that talking about a trip and all that
[ __ ] in a conversation I feel usually
you get to know a person before you open
up to them about like the drugs you've
taken clearly this guy doesn't give a
[ __ ]
I only that but he offered you drugs
[ __ ] [ __ ] and guys and then and guys
and then his drives he a DMT trip that
he had all within 15 minutes of meeting
him yeah he's a Salesman true salesman
true salesman so we went back with a few
guys and did some DMT and then and the
horse came over that's when it got weird
yeah you know new horse want some DMT
I'm not sure what or is usually you guys
spoke with DMT at all I'm just sorry I
don't do the [ __ ] thing very often so
goddamn it just hella rude but not
knowing that it's rude it's just
insensitive anyway yeah so then whatever
we didn't see that guy oh no he was like
he was punishing me with conversation to
the point that I text Tom I said get me
out of here really isn't that the point
where you like kind of edge him on like
what else do you got no I couldn't take
it okay cuz he just is he was definitely
weird I I didn't like him either
immediately I was like just bad vibe
there was no there's no look there's
nothing cohesive about the city was
saying it was just frustrating to
listening to him talk because it was
like listening to me you know like the
thoughts just keep bouncing around I
just couldn't keep up and I said it's
okay if I do it to other people but I
don't want this done to me but I don't
need to be on the receiving end of this
[ __ ] so he just kept jumping around a
different [ __ ]
he claimed like Solange lived in one of
those houses he's a guy give her weed
and show them like whatever cool manner
he didn't yeah whatever he said some
other [ __ ] that I was just kind of like
all right I've had enough yeah um Tom
got me the [ __ ] up out of there but then
I remember Matt telling me about his
golf cart mmm and he's a gay took him
around the block [ __ ] was cool in my art
I remember walking back to my room
seeing this yellow golf cart with rock
star stickers all over no way sure and
then I showed it to Matt I'm like this
is like yeah that's the [ __ ] golf
cart couldn't believe it the guy
literally lived like one Street over
from the hotel rockstar golf cart yeah
dudes living a life that guys by the way
she was also like probably like almost
40 yeah probably yeah oh that was the
thing that he um he started getting into
stories about himself like taking drugs
he goes I don't [ __ ] with Lucy anymore
man and and Steve was you know engaging
him our merge dude so he you know David
they were kind of I was like
eavesdropping a little bit not user I
was in and out of the conversation and
he's telling Steve he doesn't [ __ ] with
Lucy anymore because I used to take it
all the time man when I was working at
FedEx dude
my buddy introduced me to Dex a train
and whoever the [ __ ] that is extreme I
don't know it was like wasn't if I
definitely [ __ ] that name up but it
would started with Dex uh something
dexedrine Dexter Dexter some Dexter
whatever sure that's in robitussin maybe
I'm wrong I don't think it is
I don't know okay he said yeah I used to
do I got right into that chair used to
pop 400 milligrams of that then I'd then
I'd micro dose and I was working at UPS
and I would I was just throwing boxes
all day you know I'm saying cuz I had
the night shift so I party all day then
I do that at night and work eight hours
and I just rinse repeat man and
everyone's like how do you have such a
good attitude it's cuz I'm on [ __ ]
Lucy dot that just that whole multiply
that times ten minutes like this guy was
overload everything he was saying was
just insane I couldn't handle it that's
kind of a funny character
dude this got like just absurd stories
about everything yeah like no matter
what you bring up he's like all doing up
you yeah exactly every single [ __ ] that
reminds me of the time I [ __ ] was a
landscaper and I used to be on Molly all
the time and one time I [ __ ] cut this
guy's hedges into boobs and he got so
mad if he shot me in the knee man that
takes me back yeah I did Molly acrost I
made it I kissed somebody that was crazy
yeah dude damn dude and she was so high
on bath salts she bit my tongue off bro
so get this I'm running down the street
I can't like say anything is my tongues
bit off and I'm spraying blood out of my
mouth and I just [ __ ] found my tongue
randomly in the street and I [ __ ] put
that [ __ ] on ice took it back to the
hospital them shits they sewed it on but
then I [ __ ] so I'm in the hospital
right I start coming down and I realize
I never cut my tongue out I was tripping
the whole time but then what's [ __ ] up
is they thought I was on some other [ __ ]
so they give me this [ __ ] drug and I
got super tripped out bro so I came down
and I came right back up and I guess I
[ __ ] all over the walls and started like
writing my name and cursive and and all
kinds of crazy stuff yes that's how I
got banned from
Mobile Alabama yeah I can't party there
anymore man I thought I was in Amsterdam
turns out I don't even have a passport
flicks trying to flex take your vision
notion break that's not a flex